[Music]
foreign
's Department of Human Services is to
support the well-being of individuals
families and communities with support
programs that Foster self-sufficiency
shepherding people into Support Services
takes communication people apply for
programs and benefits DHS processes them
demand for these services from the
community is a good thing it signals the
value people found in the programs but
like any system spikes in demand can
create bottlenecks like longer callback
weights and longer processing time to
address this the Department of Human
Services adopted Google Cloud contact
center AI here with us to discuss is
systems analyst Ethan Chao
let's dive a little deeper on the tech
side
we'll start with contact center AI
platform or ccaip which controls how
calls are connected
all routing is managed through queues
and here we have several set up
the dialog flow queue connects callers
to our virtual agent which is where
they're immediately sent when dialing in
you'll see a few cues with a tier number
these correspond with our tiered support
system or call if started a low tier and
are escalated to higher tiers as
necessary so these queues route College
to those tiered agents
there's a voicemail queue to allow folks
to leave voicemails and we also have
this queue down here which transfers
callers out to a third-party line from
within the virtual agent
next up is our CRM integration we've
configured ccaip to work with servicenow
the system we use to record customer
interactions as soon as someone calls we
create a record in servicenow to start
logging their conversation with the
virtual agent then when the customer
gets transferred to a human agent ccaip
automatically opens that servicenow
record on the agent's screen allowing
them to see information about the caller
it also updates the record with
additional metadata once the call is
over
here we've set the URL template used to
automatically open the appropriate
record on screen
in each of these endpoint configurations
we use a gcp cloud function as a middle
layer between ccaip and servicenow this
allows us to add additional logic or
functionality
here's an example of one endpoint config
the upload a file endpoint
this endpoint uploads call transcripts
voicemail recordings and session
metadata to the servicenow record
finally let's look at dialog flow where
we built the virtual agent that
interacts with callers we've built out a
number of flows dedicated to frequently
asked questions or topics
each flow has various pages that provide
the information they'd need
for example if someone calls in about an
interview they'll enter this interview
flow and here we'll provide them with
information about if and or when their
interview is scheduled
for example in this page
we tell the caller that they do not have
an interview scheduled
to do this we need to retrieve
information from a back-end Java server
that can access a bunch of information
about these cases
again we used Cloud functions as a
middle layer to communicate with the
Java backend
with contact center AI platform Hawaii's
Department of Human Services was better
able to support their citizens
increasing the number of cases they
could handle while reducing weight and
processing times they were also able to
prioritize interactions appropriately
and make each engagement relevant to the
citizen
to learn how you can integrate contact
center AI into your customer experience
check out the links in the description
below
foreign
[Music]